is this true you did a national food
commercial when you were quite young
when you were starting out you did a
commercial but it was sort of an
accident is that right into a commercial
setting you know
before before the TV shows and movies
and stuff you just a comedy guy a comedy
guy a comedian you know hustling and
stuff like that and I did I didn't do a
commercial I did this little bit cuz I I
was actually kind of making fun of
McDonald's I'm gonna say this right now
I don't like McDonald's so sorry
so it's all festive I don't get me
started anyway sorry everyone's like
they're bitter stop waving their
American flags wait what yeah anyway but
I don't like it's those guys pay our
bills okay that's right well enjoy a new
sponsor because they're pulling their
funding anyway but I was like kind of
making fun of you know how lot you know
when the whole I'm loving it thing was
happening yeah orbán like oh yeah you
know I don't know and so I was doing
this thing where it's like I was just
rapping about Chicken McNuggets
as as kind of like a parody and then I
put it online and it became viral and in
the early days of things going viral
yeah this is like well I mean it was
YouTube was around but no one there
weren't like six million fan right well
with their own channel and stuff like
that and then if you can find them in
McDonald's like hot it and put it in a
commercial and I'm standing there like
I'm teasing you and you're paying me for
we take I think we have the commercial
use justice in Chicago right yeah yeah
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
to see